I need the cans or well you don't have
to wear the headphones if you don't want
to good I mean if you want to hear the
full richness of my voice then put on
the headphones yes pretty Doc Rivers
tomorrow yes I see Misawa at 7:27 21
that's the guy who doesn't want to play
golf until 10:30 and now you got him at
7:20 it's doc any good at going yes doc
let's put it this way you know our first
tee right yes and a lot of guys hit it
into 18 it's intimidating at first no
but a lot of guys sitting in 18 and then
there's 17 next 18 I have seen doc twice
hit it not only over 18 but over 17 to
the right rough on 17 and make birdie
from there it's um when doc is on the
tee there is no say are we on the air
you never know you I figure you guys are
sold out in commercial break no doc can
hit the ball about 3:30 but you know
nobody is safe on the golf course within
three holes of doc on the tee and Alan
belongs to bel-air so the you you have
the veranda there where people are
having their breakfast or lunch and you
go out for the first tee the putting
green is to your left and so you have
people right there as you tee off and
you know there's some famous people who
could be out there watching you a little
bit so it can't be intimidating and a
lot of heckling - and Bob Newhart's
always out there and he's heckling
heckling me yeah but one of the great
we're in the great comedians but but are
you sort of like Fritzi are you allowed
to heckle at Bellaire on the first tee
yes you can heckle if you've been there
a member for over 20 years heckling is
allowed otherwise it's verboten that's
it so yes it's quite a scene yeah mm-hmm
yeah in fact I think that Bob Newhart
was sitting out there he didn't say
anything when I I was with Rick
Neuheisel right and when we play good
player very good player great player yes
and but I didn't I didn't get any grief
from anybody like they were they were
respectful they just wanted to see if I
was gonna make contact and then once I
did then they were like okay nothing to
see here like there was nothing nothing
good about it they thought
Rich Eisen Wow yeah okay
would you like to call golf I have I've
done the I've done for Tiger Woods
primetime shows we started in 99 out
here at Sherwood and he faced David
Duval they were 1 & 2 in the world and
then we took the show to Bighorn the
Battle of Bighorn out in the desert you
know so I did I did the first four shows
what I like to call golf um no not
really because you have to you know
you're there for five or six days and I
just played golf the other day with our
buddy Jim Nantz who's Jim jim has set
the standard for announcing golf I mean
when I watch golf I have to hear Jim's
voice he's phenomenal I mean he and golf
are just totally intertwined so you know
I've done too many I've done so many
other sports as you know and you know
once you've done the world barrel
jumping championships and motorcycles on
ice where do you go from there Dan where
do you go but I was wondering okay I
don't know if this is true or not but
your first job in TV you chose women to
appear on the dating game that would be
correct we would I work for Chuck Barris
productions rated yeah created the the
gong show and we were I was part of a
group that we would cold call people and
try to get them to come down to audition
for the dating game and at that time the
newlywed game had just started up so and
I was part of the process where I would
be in there is if we had four or five
guys and we would pick the girls are the
guys to go in the dating game and I had
just got married to and my wife had to
get a job there to make sure that there
was nothing else going on and of course
Linda and I have now been married you
know for 114 years and love her to death
and it all worked out then you you broke
into sports you were hired by the Lakers
to do PR correct and then do you were a
color analyst for for chick earned for
just a little bit for eight games yeah I
did if I did the four preseason games
and well maybe six regular-season games
so what had happened in those years is
that chick had only in check maybe the
best basketball announcer of all time he
and Marv Albert like in my mind are the
best ever
and so chick did not want to work with a
color announcer or an animal
so jack kent cooke wanted hot rod
Hundley who had just retired to have
that job so I was used as kind of
without knowing it a sacrificial lamb to
come in there and do a few games that
Jerry West was playing on that team Here
I am I'm like 22 years old I'm the one
I'm the color announcer for the Lakers
but chip would never let me do anything
except read the statistics at halftime
so I did so that's a team that had Jerry
West Elgin Baylor Mel counts
Archie Clark Gail Goodrich so Wow you
know it's you know these guys were you
know I was analyzing them and then we
were making it a road trip to Boston and
Cincinnati and I was not only the color
announcer I was the traveling secretary
I had everybody's plane tickets they're
all flying commercial in those years I
get to the airport I'm handing out the
tickets to the guys and bill van retic
off is the coach gets out of the cab and
says give me the tickets don't get on
the plane go call the guy at the
California Sports Allen Rothenberg and
he wants to talk to you so here I am
I've got to get my bag off the plane
it's already on the plane but I got it
there it is it's coming around the
camera so I get it I go to rothenburg's
office and I'm fired simple as that yeah
and the jack kent cooke always told me
he was doing me a favor I said you know
you're doing me some favor you know you
got fired I got fired only time in my
life
correct mm-hmm did you almost give up
nope
and she got hired in Hawaii yes so that
came afterwards maybe eight or nine
months after that yeah and then Hawaii
was the big break tremendous a guy named
man named Jack Quinn was the general
manager yeah I left a tape with him I'd
gone over there and my audition was my
tape from Arizona State where I had gone
to school and I'm doing baseball at a
time when Sal bando is my classmate sal
is there Rick Monday is a year behind
yet great and then when I was a junior a
freshman but the name of Reggie Jackson
showed up you know and Bobby winkles was
the coach and I got hired on the basis
of that by the Hawaii Islanders in 1968
and
that was the trampoline if you could
teach a class and then play-by-play how
what would that class encompass well a
number of things I you know I've always
been I don't want to say less is more
but you don't have to over talk
especially on television see the great
thing about radio is you can use verbs
because you're describing things you're
painting the picture for the listener on
television they can see they can see the
verb if you know what I mean yeah so
you're speaking more maybe an ellipsis
and that sort of thing but I mean to me
the games always been the thing let the
game play out don't overdo it try you
know intersperse some stories and I
think you know what we trying to do on
Sunday night and you know Cris
Collinsworth is off the charts
unbelievable and you know Michelle does
a great job on the sidelines but let's
just let the folks enjoy the game and
try to be I don't want to say minimalist
but again less is more you don't need
non-stop chatter and that would be one
of the things though you know I could
tell our class a million different
things but generally that should be the
way you go about it and also let it be
organic and dynamic and don't go in
thinking that I'm gonna say this say
that the whole thing we it so much as if
you're reading off a script you know
kind of let it flow and with more
experience obviously you can trust your
instincts more when was the last time
that you were like truly surprised
during a game that even though you
prepare for everything you were still
surprised well in terms of how the game
plays out you mean the incident or just
I mean there were that you know you
don't expect certain things but having
done all of these games you're kind of
ready to roll you know how to you know
get to where something is happening that
you didn't expect
so I mean well I mean I look back at my
career the me the biggest surprise of
all would be when the earth begins to
move and the 1989 World Series yeah so
that was that was a little bit different
apart from that you know when the you
know you study for the games and
and all of that and you think you know
what's gonna happen but when it doesn't
you know you can roll with it and that
just comes from experience like you're
watching Nick Foles last year right
going into the Super Bowl are you
telling yourself that Nick Foles can do
this or is there still that doubt no
youyou thought that he could do it
because remember this was a guy who not
that long ago had a year in which he had
27 touchdown passes and two
interceptions for Chip Kelly at
Philadelphia so this is this is no bum
this is a guy who can do it but he
always retired he almost retired the
story was great obviously and we had you
know spoken to him a couple of times we
had done Philadelphia down the stretch
and we'd actually done you know a game
against Atlanta in the playoffs with
them so we gotten to normally we've
gotten to know we've gotten to know him
back in 2013 so I didn't see him being
the MVP of the Superbowl but I thought
you know the way he was playing at the
end of the season the way he played in
the playoffs the way he played against
Minnesota and and if she championship
game I thought there was a chance that
he could lead them to a victory it was a
great story made fabulous yeah and then
you look at the Eagles this like it can
go so quickly with these teams and
that's what makes the Patriots amazing
is somehow someway they keep you know
reshuffling that lineup but at one at
some point it ends for Tom Brady at some
point he finds the Ledge there and steps
off right it ends for all of us then
just in case you we're just in the wind
you know that do you think that Brady
ends his career as a patriot I do okay
yeah I do know I don't know when you
know it's so funny because somebody's a
week-to-week thing oh he looks great now
he looks terrible you know the way it is
meanwhile everybody you know has tried
to bury the Patriots at one time or
another for all of these years but but
they can't look at a certain point it
will end we just don't know when it will
you know my feeling is hey just enjoy it
people are going hey should he should he
play should he not play you know I would
like to see his career and similarly to
John Elway very few people have that
kind of an ending but a Tom deserves
that I
if they won the Super Bowl last year he
would have retired I'm not sure about
that he loved you see the thing about
Tom he loves what he does he loves it
and once you step away I don't think you
can ever recreate that buzz you can't I
mean time I'll have a great you know
afterlife as well he can do a lot of
different things what do you think he'll
do do you think he'd ever be an analyst
doubtful doubtful I think he would like
to maybe be a part owner they seem very
I see him in a similar vein as Peyton
Manning you know i Peyton's had a chance
to to be an analyst you name it I mean
everybody would have hired Peyton would
you rather have as an analyst if you
don't have Collinsworth and I give you
Brady or Manning they're very different
you know Peyton Peyton has a lot of
external energy is the way I would put
it so I think it depends what you're
looking for I think Brady would be I
don't want to say more cerebral when
they're both gigantically smart there's
no question about that I mean it's it's
almost a coin flip in a way and I'm not
begging the question I think they would
come out with come at you with different
styles but I know one thing about those
two guys if they got into the business
they would work like crazy they work as
hard at this business as they did at
being a quarterback and they would be
how good would they be I don't know but
they'd be very good if I said we're
talking about Michaels by the way a
belated happy birthday
oh please did you celebrate if nominated
I will not run if elected I will not
serve we just don't do the math but
thank you anyway guys I just wanted to
Scott of course they did okay yeah
because I tried to get a steak cake made
for you a steak cake yeah it's something
new but it's trying to get it made
nobody could come up with a steak your
dad Patrick that's you know that's
that's what I thought there when you
look at being able to cover this sport
and then you're trying to handicap this
the rest of the season right as you
you'll see a team and you go boy they're
they're awesome what do you see yeah
they like and we overreact to this do
you overreact to this I try not to
because we live in this
old of you know what have you done for
me lately everybody I mean it dan we
live in a world of blow VA ssin yeah
except for the Dan Patrick show and you
know and ik and a couple of others so
everybody's got you know the the the hot
take the fresh take be over whatever I
don't know
it look to me my feelings always been
nobody knows anything right nobody knows
squat so when people say who's gonna be
in the Superbowl I don't know who's
gonna be in the Superbowl
so if you were to say today okay so the
Saints look great they look great on
November you know the 13th are they
gonna look great I have no idea I have
no idea but that's why look the essence
of sports and why I've always loved
sports is you don't know you might think
you know but you don't then it plays out
and it's exciting coming up on Sunday
it'll be the Vikings at the Bears on
Sunday Night Football and that's another
thing where you know it's always
interesting where you're trying to
figure out okay what's gonna happen in a
game now we throw in the gambling eyes
aspect where you've sort of had fun with
it you like to you like to put your hand
on the fire or close to the fire just a
little bit there is there is there any
fire at all anymore like can can we just
be open about the point spread or the
over/under is or would you rather be
covert I'd rather be covert I've had fun
being a rascal through the years you
know you throw in little nuanced
references to things this game isn't
over we're not supposed to mention
certain things there was a game in
Kansas City was 45 10 against Cincinnati
a couple of weeks ago and and I could
there was a murmuring in the crowd when
the Chiefs were gonna sit on the ball
and not go for a field goal or a
touchdown like I knew what it was and
I'm thinking well the crowd is thinking
about the number 56 and a half right now
so I guess we're you know we're not
supposed to do certain things but people
love it and I know the gambling sites
called me an American icon after that or
whatever so it's it's it's fun to play
the rascal role once in a while it's
great to see how as always Vikings at
the Bears that'll be coming up on Sunday
Night Football and once again happy
birthday and you've got Doc Rivers
getting up tomorrow morning at 7:20
fritzy got him you know Will Ferrell got
up to come in at 6:00
unbelievable that is crazy what did you
think of Seaton you know Steve Ballmer's
Seaton's in person I thought it was
fantastic I was watching I happen to be
watching the game last night it's it's
crazy it really is yeah
well that's the way he remember he used
to do that when he was at Microsoft yeah
that's where we saw it right he wanted
to be Steve Jobs because Jobs came out
of the t-shirt the whole thing and
bomber used to do it I mean it's gonna
kill you do it for Alan just first that
was very cool but you had it done right
on baby that'll play The Comedy Store
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]